l'ambiance qu'il y a maintenant une
équipe de france n'est pas celle du
caillou à quelques années auparavant
parce que vraiment nous étions comme des
pestiférés en équipe de france il n'est
même pas justement parce qu'à un moment
donné nous étions vraiment coupe
d'antillais et puis on se tenait pour
garder de vaud vous êtes hyper su
comment les coureurs antillais et très
certainement nous gênions y avait trois
d'antillais vous veniez pourquoi parce
que nous y étions trop nombreuses
touches supplément pour nombreuses au
meilleur est peut-être meilleur quand
vous revenez à lamartine ennemis vous
êtes enseignante
vous avez peut-être même la possibilité
de pouvoir donner un coup de main à la
ligue d'athlétisme
pourquoi est ce que vous n'avez pas fait
on se sent rejetée on se sent vraiment
regretter quand on arrive ici on a
l'impression qu'on gêne comment est-ce
qu'on peut expliquer justement qu'on
puisse priver justement de de tels
talents hall au delà de la jalousie
c'est un point d'interrogation pour moi
aussi je ne sais rien ils veulent pas de
nous on ne veut pas de nous pourquoi on
ne sait pas